In Israel, Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu...
...says he plans to name a new settlement in the occupied Golan Heights...
...for US President Donald Trump...
...in appreciation of his recognition of Israel's claim of sovereignty there.
In Sri Lanka, Prime Minister Ranil Wickremesinghe...
...gives a press conference on the Easter Sunday bombings...
...as mourners and families of some of the 320-plus victims...
...hold memorial services for their loved ones.
In Egypt, President Abdel Fattah al-Sisi hosts an emergency summit in Cairo with African leaders...
...on the upheavals in Sudan and Libya,...
...amid fears instability could spill over into neighboring countries.
In India, one person is dead and several others are injured...
...after multiple clashes erupt during polling in the West Bengal province.
Finally from the United States, Senate Judiciary Chairman Lindsey Graham...
...says "there's going to be a stampede to impeach Trump,"...
...as Democratic leaders move to deepen their investigation of Trump.